in assembly Theory we talk about the
four universes the assembly Universe the
assembly possible and the assembly
contingent and then the assembly
observed and they're all all scales in
this combinatorial universe yeah can you
explain each one of them yep so the
assembly universe is like anything goes
just as just coment toal kind of
explosion in everything so that's the
biggest one that's the biggest one it's
massive assembly Universe assembly
possible assembly contingent assembly
observed and uh on the y- axis is
assembly steps in time yeah and you know
in the x-axis as as the thing expands
Through
Time more and more unique objects appear
so yeah so assembly universe everything
goes y um assembly possible laws of
physics come in in this case in
chemistry bonds mhm in assembly so that
means those are actually constraints I
guess yes and they're the only
constraints they're the straints at the
base so the way to look at you got all
your atoms they're quantied you can just
bung them together so then you can
become a kind of so in the way in
computer science speak I suppose the
assembly universe is just like no laws
of physics things can fly through
mountains beyond the speed of light in
in the assembly possible you have to
apply the laws of physics but you can
get access to all the motifs
instantaneously with no effort that
means you could make anything then the
assembly contingent says no you can't
have access to the highly assembled
object in the future until you've done
the work in the past on the causal chain
and that's really the really interesting
shift where you go from assembly um
possible to assembly contingent that is
really the key thing in assembly theory
that says you cannot just have
instantaneous access to all those
memories you have to have done the work
somehow the universe has to somehow
built a um a system that allows you to
select that path um rather than other
paths and then the final thing the
assembly observed is basically saying oh
these are the things we actually see we
can go backwards now and understand that
they have been created by this this
causal process wait a minute so when you
say the universe has to construct the
system that does the work is that like
the environment that that that allows
for like selection yeah yeah yeah that's
the thing that does The Selection you
could think about in terms of a Von
noyman Constructor first selection a
ribosome a Tesla plant assembling Teslas
you know the the difference between the
assembly Universe in Tesla land and the
the Tesla Factory is everyone says no
Teslas are just easy they just spring
out you know how to make them all the
Tesla Factory you have to put things in
sequence and out comes a Tesla so you're
talking about the factory yes this is
this is really nice super important
point is that when I talk about the
universe having a memory or there's some
magic it's not that it's that tells you
that there must be a process encoded
somewhere in physical reality be it a
cell a Tesla Factory or something else
that is making that object I'm not
saying there's some kind of woow woo
memory in the universe you know morphic
resonance or something I'm saying that
there is an actual causal process that
is being directed constrained in some
way um so it's not kind of just making
everything yeah but Le what's the
Factory they made the
factory so what what is the so first of
all you assume the laws of physics as uh
just sprung to existence at the
beginning those are constraints but what
what makes the factory is the
environment that does The Selection this
is the question of well it's the first
interesting question that I want to
answer out of four I think the factory
emerges in the envir the interplay
between the environment and the objects
that are being being built mhm and and
here let me I'll have a go explain to
you the the shortest path so why is the
shortest path important imagine you've
got um I'm going to have to go chemistry
for a moment then abstract it um so
imagine you've got an envir A given
environment that um that you have a
budget of atoms you're just flinging
together yep and the the objective of
those atoms that being flung together in
say molecule a um have to make they have
they de compos so molecules decompose
over time so the
molecules um in this environment in this
magic environment have to not die but
they do die there's a there's they have
a half life so the only way the
molecules can get through that
environment out the other side let
pretend the environment is a box and go
in and out without dying and there's a
there's just an infinite supply of atoms
coming or well a large
Supply the the molecule gets built but
the molecule that is able to template
itself being built MH um and survives in
the environment will will basically re
Supreme now let's say that molecule
takes 10
steps now and it and it's using a finite
set of atoms right or now let's say
another molecule smart ass molecule
we'll call it comes in yeah and can
survive in that
environment and can copy itself but it
only needs five
steps the molecule that only needs five
steps CU it's Contin both are being
destroyed but they're creating
themselves faster they can be destroyed
you can see that the shortest path
Reigns Supreme so the shortest path
tells us something super interesting
about the minimal amount of uh
information required to propagate that
Motif in time and space um and it's just
like a kind of it seems to be like some
kind of conservation law so one of the
intuitions you have is the propagation
of motifs in time will be done by the
things that can construct themselves in
in the
shortest path yeah so like you can
assume that most of the objects in the
universe are built in the shortest in
the most efficient way that the so big
leap I just took there yeah no yeah yes
and no because there are other things so
in the limit yes because you want to
tell the difference between things that
have required a factory to build them
and just random
processes um but you can find instances
where the shortest path isn't taken for
an individual object an individual
function mhm um and people go ah that
means the shortest path isn't right and
then I say well I don't know I think
it's right still because so of course
because there are other driving forces
it's not just one molecule now when you
start to now you start to consider two
objects you have a joint assembly space
and it's not now it's a compromise
between not just making a and b in the
shorts path you want to make a and b in
the shorts path which might mean that a
is slightly longer you have compromise
so when you see slightly more nesting in
the construction when you take a given
object that can look longer but that's
because the overall function is the
object is still trying to be efficient
yeah and this is still very
handwavy um and maybe have no leg to
stand on but we think we're getting
somewhere with that and there's probably
some parallelization yeah right so this
is all this not sequential the building
is yeah I guess when you're when you're
talking about complex objects you you
don't have to work sequentially you can
work in parallel you can get your
friends together and they can yeah these
and the the thing we're working on right
now is how to understand these parallel
processes now there's an in a new thing
we've introduced called assembly depth
and ass assembly depth can be lower than
the assembly index for a molecule when
they're cooperating together because
exactly this parallel processing is
going on and my team have been working
this out in the last few weeks because
we're looking at what compromises does
nature need to make when it's making
molecules in the cell and I I wonder if
you know I I maybe like well I'm always
leaping out of um my competence but in
economics I'm just wondering if you
could apply this in economic process it
seems like capitalism is very good at
finding shortest path you know every
time but ludicrous things that happen
because actually the cost function has
been minimized and so I keep seeing
parallels everywhere where there are
complex nested systems where if you give
it enough time and you introduce a bit
of heterogeneity the system readjusts
and finds a new shorts path but the
shortest path isn't fixed on just one
molecule now it's in the actual
existence of the object over time and
that object could be a city it could be
a cell it could be a factory but I think
we're going Way Beyond molecules and and
my competence so probably should go back
to molecules but
hey